procedure
what do you guys think do you think men
should have a say in abortion
yeah because it's their is their child
being born as well okay you know i think
it's a joint commitment
in the idle world i would it would be
great to have 50 50
with that but
once you were bought like if a guy wants
the baby right
if the guy wants a baby once you were
bought if he's if you two are together
for instance right and you say you know
what i know we're together but i don't
want this child
does he just is he ever right just leave
you after that
do you think he's just like all right
bye
that's a big thing you know that's a
that's the same as like marriage
if he wants to get married and you
didn't right that at that point in time
and you say like i'm not ready he can
still leave yeah you know i think
because what's he supposed to do like go
to the abortion clinic review to kill
his child at the same time i do think
women
women have to carry the baby it changes
their body it changes you know the
hormones going in in
in their brain in the blood so i do
think at the end of the day it does come
down to the woman but i definitely think
that's why we need to be so careful when
choosing the people we sleep with
because it should be a decision that
both of you make together right although
it is in the women's body and everything
and ultimately it does come down to her
we need to be careful who we're sleeping
with
so these issues don't arise you know and
talk about it beforehand i think the
question off camera
is a good one because
we're getting to the point now where you
get the conflation between
what men and women can actually do with
their bodies versus what we think is
morally right right so for me you're
talking about that great area the gray
bit that massive gray area that we're
talking about see because the way i see
it is is that what you've just said
there is spot honest your body
so therefore
i'm on the side of if you don't want the
child
then maybe at that point would be the
woman's decision
because she has to go through something
that men can never go through right so
the the the constant pursuit of equality
in society this is where it gets messed
up because we're not equal
we can't we cannot give birth as men so
therefore if the conversation is the
woman wants to have the child
because you're you're the incubator
but the man doesn't want it that's i
think that is a separate debate versus
the same question in reverse because the
physical uh
the physicality of actually having a
baby
but it's not our body
it's the kids body it's a unique dna
sequence that's unique from the mother
and the fathers from the moment of
conception i understand that but i was
just answering the question
so you think she should
have full control
i didn't say full control but i think if
if there is a case where she doesn't
want to have the child
this is where it gets so great i
actually feel like if she doesn't want
to have the child then she should have
the right to say that she doesn't want
to have the child but if she doesn't you
don't it's a dif that's a different
question because we're not men and women
are different
but it's sorry this is what i was
wanting to ask earlier like you know
is
plain devil's advocate advocate is is it
her child so is it a body because you
know if she was
let's say the baby was a boy would you
now say she has a dick you know i i
doubt you would because
it's not her body if that makes sense no
but it's her body that's carrying the
baby yes but you still understand
we understand what you're getting at but
it's like so for example it's me yeah
i'm carrying the baby so if i don't want
to go through the physical changes i
have the right to say not that i agree
with abortion but you can do that eight
months you can change your mind at eight
months
but is it different why is it different
what makes you different the process and
the the chemicals
in some states in america you're still
allowed to make that decision well here
you're allowed to up to six months which
is good which is crazy because the
earliest baby that survived from um
giving birth is 21 weeks and it's legal
at 24.
so a baby that's survived on its own at
21 weeks and at 24 they can still abort
it
and that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying because at what point does it
stop being oh this is my body my choice
because if the argument is my body my
choice then you should be able to abort
up to nine months exactly
which in certain places in america they
were actually advocating for yeah i mean
there's even places in america i mean a
senator got caught talking about how
um if a woman has an abortion and the
baby survives that they can't give that
baby medical treatment yeah
like a senator got caught and planned
parenthood also got caught selling body
parts of children to research clinics
yes they did
but nobody ever cares about that or
talks about that they don't i got a
solution for all this if the woman
doesn't want to have the child then i'll
take the childhood every day
that's what i do with all my children i
said if you don't want to have the child
i'll take it full time and you don't
have to have anything to do with it
that's what you're going to do about the
nine months before exactly
the whole nine months that's almost a
year of her life but again
but it's the same argument you make for
men who you have children they don't
want it's like you decided to have sex
one at a time sorry sorry
for 18 years i have to look after the
kid
which is why it should be a choice
between the both of you right so what
i'm saying when we're making a choice
we're making a choice of casual sex
we're not making the choice of
having a baby every time not every time
you have casual sex you have the choice
i mean not every time you have casual
sex you want to have a baby right
because you're not a virgin and you
haven't got a child so that means you
you have you're allowed to have the
choice whether or not you're allowed to
have casual sex as a woman as a man we
should be able to have casual sex
without the chance of you getting
pregnant especially when there's so many
contraceptions for you to like
not get pregnant even after the baby's
been conceived no one's saying for you
to wait six months there's a more than
afterpill there's a three-day pill
there's
there's different ways and i'm saying
this to say
we if we had more of a choice maybe it
would be more fairer okay but
respectfully there are also male
contraceptive yes so if you want to have
casual sex take a male contraceptive um
but they're not readily available at
this point male countries can also
question about the only the only thing
that's available is a condom but girls
can still steal those the nba is issued
statements to nba players saying to
flush your condoms because women are
stealing them but you all heard what
happened with drake okay go ahead go
ahead go ahead can't you reverse a
vasectomy
yeah that's a surge i think there's a
difference between a surgical procedure
which can be irreversible
versus birth control morning after pill
which i mean there are side effects from
sure
but i think we can agree a vasectomy is
like one step further yeah but if
if you want to be having casual sex like
that and you really don't want to
get someone pregnant you're not taking
those precautions beforehand before
sleeping with someone then shouldn't you
do that that's what i'll point to but
that's the point the same with the women
like shouldn't you do that shouldn't you
think about that before you get an
abortion
so that's why i'm saying like they
shouldn't have a bailout because they
made their bed lie in it are you
advocating for men to have vasectomies
so are you saying no oh okay
i'm saying if you want to sleep around
and not deal with any of the
consequences like if you're not taking
the time to find out who the woman is
before like if she will listen to your
point of view if you can have a
conversation about it etc then go have a
vasectomy and sleep with whoever you
want you don't have to deal with any of
those consequences you know yeah would
you sorry yeah i was going to say the
same thing for you do you see how do you
see it do you see the double standards
right so for you for you it's my body i
could choose what i want and for me you
should have you should have you should
have took precautions it's your problem
if you have it so now i'm saying to you
if it was it was switched around to you
now and say okay we have casual sex but
abortion is not allowed you have to have
you have to have um the kid you would
soon see how many women not have kids
because they're not going to jump on now
because
because a man could say the same thing
vet who you sleep with why are you
sleeping with someone who wouldn't be a
good father exactly or just get your
tubes tied yeah or get your tears get
your tube side at what 18 years old if
you're gonna have casual sex that's it's
a crazy thing to ask a young person to
do right do you know what i mean like
because you don't know what decisions
you're gonna be making into your future
life like to ask to advocate for men
having vasectomies like
to stop them producing sperm
i don't think that's realistic that
that's um an extreme
would you ask your kids
would you ask your kid sorry could you
ask your male son to take a vasectomy i
would say you need to be careful who you
sleep with drunk right either way
you see there we go now so you're not
gonna you're not gonna do it for your
son you're not gonna do it for your son
you're gonna tell him watch out the same
thing you tell your daughter watch out
do you know what i mean but at the end
of the day the woman still has the
choice whether or not she could have the
kid or not so where we can't have casual
sex as men
we always have to have that something
over us knowing that if anyhow the
condom breaks because it's 99 percent
accurate it's not 100
so
there's a chance it could happen even if
we wear condom but you have a lot of
different
ways to stop that kid from actually
being on the earth to the point of the
kid being here so when the kid is
actually here you've passed all of those
contraceptions and now you're saying
that guy is a deadbeat because he's not
around
so you didn't know you didn't know that
before
male contraception should just be more
ready readily available i'm not i'm not
vouching for one or the other i'm just
saying think about who you sleep with
and
there are ways around it i think the
issue is that
you know there's people in states now in
america where abortion is going to be
banned would you make that same argument
to them that oh it's not that deep just
you know be careful you have sex with
and be careful when you have sex
yes so
no no don't get me wrong i agree i agree
that you should say that yeah i agree
with you he's saying would you say the
same thing to women like be careful he
like now because in in certain states in
the us abortion is going to be banned so
if the girls in those states would you
say the same thing like it's not that
big of a deal just be careful who you
sleep with yeah okay
it's a choice we have a base group women
today yeah when you look back at the
history of of contraception
the liberation of women sexually came
with the invention of the pill
yes so it is in effect
the the
the get out of jail free card is
actually a bit of a curse in many
respects right because the the casual
nature of having
you know a modern-day relationship
normally centers around sex most of the
time
so you've got like you said those
contraceptions in place where you can
actually go and say well you know what i
can go and do my thing because i've got
this pill that pill that implant that
safety yeah but what i want to ask is a
big question
you mentioned contraception and i want
to ask you in the context of abortion do
you guys consider the morning after pill
and pills of that ilk to be abortions i
have gotten this question so many very
very interesting great
questions i don't have a good answer to
be honest i've i really want to
interview an abortion and like
contraceptive doctor in the uk about
this type of stuff so if anyone knows
anyone in the uk i could interview i
really would like to because i don't
have a good answer i don't know it's a
good question though because i think
it's it kind of is is that great bit
isn't it where you don't is it an
abortion is it not you know because you
could say you
you could say you could say because she
could be pregnant from the night before
she could be that could have been
conception night right because i i want
to say and this is just from people like
coming on my show and explaining this so
this isn't like
you know factually i haven't double
checked this but i want to say it's the
egg and the sperm have already met and
it's just like it's swimming basically
to the next step and it makes it stop is
that like
i don't know and so i think the argument
is that because the egg and the sperm
have met already
that it could be considered an
abortion arguably i don't know i don't
clearly by the way i explained this so
is the egg alive or is the sperm alive
i i don't know that's it i don't think i
love it
because okay so
after the morning after would just be
the sperm entering inside of the egg
right
because any girls get rid of their eggs
anyway every month
right men when they have like
enjoyment with themselves
you're getting rid of um sperm as it is
uh-huh so are all those billions of
sperms alive
well they're moving so i guess so yeah
of course so are you
are you mass murdering them
no but i think i think it's because of
the sperm and that but
i don't know i think it's because the
sperm and the egg have already met
in this i don't know we had we had a guy
last week that was mass murdering three
times a day